the jurogan experience she cracks me up
she beginning of the pandemic
she has very beginning the pandemic she
hits me up she goes hey we're doing this
comedy gives back thing
and i'm interviewing adam sandler or
you're an adam sandler fan right now i
love adam sandler i [ __ ] love adam
sandler she goes hey so i'm going to
interview him but like i know you're a
fan so i thought maybe i'd invite you
over
maybe come and crash
oh i saw that
i [ __ ] that up so bad
what questions did you ask him that was
like first of all i didn't ask him any
questions i told him you know me i told
him a bunch of stories about me and he
was like
okay adam you wanna hear a great story
he's like ah sure sure and i was like uh
so anyway um when you were in college
when i was in college i was at florida
state and you came informed and and he's
just like i don't know where this is
going and i go you can't afford for the
first sight and this girl i was dating
was like ended up hanging up with you
and then they end up smoking pot with
you and alan covert and then and then i
i didn't go but and that was that was me
though and he was like ah cool cool and
this is all zoom right right zoom
there's no editing also you're not in
the room with them it's
there's a delay and whitney and i have a
tape measure so we're six feet apart
because it's covered and then and i'm so
i'm swinging i'm swinging in like a boom
mic coming in going hey adam adam uh oh
this is so bad i don't even i can't even
see it because i look at the tape
measure with doing a [ __ ] statement
taping her
coloring her hair
random [ __ ] woke colors
and then i didn't even realize it was
bad right i didn't even realize it was
joe you know that i promoted my special
right you know that i went of course and
i but i said to him i go do you have
netflix
here's the 200 million dollar deal at
netflix the first i get off the phone
big j wickerson calls me and he goes i
just want to give you a heads up we just
totally trashed you and i was like what
he goes we were up after you and we were
mocking that we were in the waiting room
watching it and i go what do you mean
mock me jay and he goes are you being
serious
i thought that interview went great
[Laughter]
i thought it was i thought it was like
perfect and he was are you drunk
no no i think i was sober and that's why
big day goes bert uh you asked adam
sandler if he had netflix
i said yeah because my special's on
netflix and he goes bert he has a 200
million dollar deal at netflix he
definitely has [ __ ] netflix and then
he goes and then you called his movie
happy madison it's happy gilmore billy
madison
he goes and then you called his movie
precious gems i go it's not pricey's
gems and then i start melting down and
i'm like oh my god i really [ __ ] this
up
yeah that was uh that was a uh
colossal and then
god bless david spade
that uncut gems movie is [ __ ]
fantastic yeah i call it precious gems
yeah if you want to find out who adam
sandler really is or what he's capable
of god damn uncut gems that is one two
hour or whatever however long the movie
is [ __ ] panic attack
obviously you haven't seen it holy [ __ ]
bird it's so good
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify